there's something really satisfying
about getting your app to look great on
your device but just because there's
over eleven thousand other Android
devices out there doesn't mean you need
to build eleven thousand other layouts
to make a great-looking app not if
you're using responsive UI principles
you may have noticed that I'm not Ian or
Joanna my name is Mike Denny a design
advocate on the Google design team first
things first
thinking about specific phones and
tablets is only going to get you into
trouble
there's a wide spectrum of devices and
not that much difference between the
largest phone and the smallest tablet
instead think more generally about how
much space you have to work with this
can come in three different flavors with
height and smallest width width is super
important and should be the basis for
breakpoints in designing and building
your UI for example 600 DP and width is
the first point where you could consider
having a side by side summary and detail
level view any lower and you won't be
giving each level a full attention it
deserves height is less common when
designing responsive UI but keep in mind
that something like a vertically
scrolling container is going to be
difficult to use if you can only see one
or two elements at a time due to a
constrained height smallest width unlike
height or width is designed to be
rotation insensitive as it's just the
smaller of the two values this gives you
a better idea of how much space is
available and is an easy way to ensure
that your app remains consistent as the
device is rotated you don't want to
force your user to relearn your
navigation structure every time they
rotate their device this is particularly
important in the multi-window world when
your app is resized your width height
and smallest width are going to be
updated you might be going from full
screen on a tablet down to what amounts
to a portrait oriented phone worth of
space here's where a good responsive UI
can make for a smooth transition there
are number of common patterns you might
consider when building that responsive
UI such as revealing previously hidden
content as the screen size grows
transforming your navigation pattern or
switching from a list to a grid dividing
your screen into multiple sections side
by side reflowing specific elements
expanding the size or margins of
individual elements
or even changing the position of
specific elements like a floating action
button check out the blog post for more
details on designing responsive UI and
specific patterns you can use to build
better apps